in this segment we developed the
inclusion exclusion formula which is a
beautiful generalization of a formula
that we have seen before let us look at
this formula and remind ourselves what
it sells if we have two sets a 1 and a 2
and we're interested in the probability
of their union how can we find it we
take the probability of the first set we
add to 8 the probability of the second
set but then we realize that by doing so
we have double counted this part of the
diagram and so we need to correct for
that and we need to subtract the
probability of this intersection and
that's how this formula comes about can
we generalize this thinking let's say to
the case of three events suppose that we
have three events a1 a2 and a3 and we
want to calculate the probability of
their union we first start by adding the
probabilities of the different sets but
then we realize that for example this
part of the diagram has been counted
twice it shows up once inside the
probability of a1 and once inside the
probability of a2 so for this reason we
need to make a correction and we need to
subtract the probability of this
intersection similarly subtract the
probability of that intersection and of
this one so we subtract the
probabilities of these intersections but
actually the intersections are not just
what I drew here the intersections also
involve this part so now let us focus on
this part of the diagram here a typical
element that belongs to all three of the
sets will show up once here once here
and once there but it will also show up
in all of these intersections and so it
shows up three times with the plus sign
three times with a minus sign which
means that these elements will not
counted at all in order to count them we
need to add one more term which is the
probability of the three-way
intersection so this is the formula for
the probability of the union of three
events it has a rationale similar to
this formula and you can convince
yourself that it is a correct formula by
just looking at the different pieces of
this diagram and make sure that each one
of them is accounted properly but
instead of working in terms of such a
picture let us think about a more formal
derivation and the formal derivation
we'll use a beautiful trick namely
indicator functions so here is the
formula that we want to establish and
let us remind ourselves what indicator
functions are 20 set or event we can
associate an indicator function let's
say that this is the set a I we are
going to associate an indicator function
call it X I which is equal to 1 when the
outcome is inside this set and it's
going to be zero when the outcome is
outside what is the indicator function
of the complement the indicator function
of the complement is 1 minus the
indicator of the event why is this if
the outcome is in the complement then X
I is equal to 0 and this expression is
equal to 1 on the other hand if the
outcome is inside a I then the indicator
function will be equal to 1 and this
quantity is going to be equal to 0 if we
have the intersection of two events AI
and AJ what is their indicator function
it is X I times XJ this expression is
equal to 1 if and only if X I is equal
to 1 and XJ is equal to 1 which happens
if and only if the outcome is inside AI
and also inside AJ
now what about the indicator of the
intersection of the complements while
it's an intersection so the Associated
indicator function is going to be the
product of the indicator function of the
first set which is 1 minus X I times the
indicator function of the second set
which is 1 minus XJ and finally what is
the indicator function of this event
here we remember the Morgan's laws the
Morgan's laws tell us that the
complement of this set the complement of
a union is the intersection of the
complements so this event here is the
complement of that event and therefore
the Associated indicator function is
going to be 1 minus this expression and
if we were dealing with more than two
sets and here we had for example 3-way
intersections you would get the product
of three terms and if we had a 3-way
union we would get a similar expression
except that here we would have again a
product of three terms instead of two so
now let us put to use what we have done
so far we are interested in the
probability that the outcome falls in
the union of three sets now an important
fact to remember is that the probability
of an event is the same as the expected
value of the indicator of that event
this is because the indicator is equal
to one if and only if the outcome
happens to be inside that set and so the
contribution that we get to the
expectation is 1 times the probability
that the indicator is
which is just this probability now the
indicator of a three-way union is going
to be by what we just discussed one - a
product of this kind but now with three
terms let us now calculate this
expectation by expanding the product
involved we have this first term then
when we multiply those three terms
together we're going to get a bunch of
contributions one contribution with a
minus sign is 1 times 1 times 1 another
contribution would be minus - that's a
plus X 1 times 1 times 1 and similarly
we get a contribution of X 2 and X 3 and
then we have a contribution such as X 1
times X 2 times 1 and if you look at the
minus signs there are 3 minus is
involved so overall it's going to be a
minus minus x1 times x2 and then there
is going to be similar terms such as x1
x3 and x2 x3 and finally there's going
to be a term x1 times x2 times x3
there's a total of 4 minus signs
involved so everything shows up in the
end with a plus sign so the probability
of this event is equal to the
expectation of this random variable here
we notice that the ones cancel out the
expected value of x1 for an indicator
variable is just the probability of that
event and we get this term the expected
value of x2 and x3 give us these terms
the expected value of x1 times x2 this
is the indicator random variable of the
intersection so the expected value of
this term is just the probability of the
intersection of a1 and a2
and similarly these terms here give rise
to those two terms here finally x1 times
x2 times x3 is the indicator variable
for the event a 1 intersection a 2
intersection a 3 therefore the expected
value of this term is equal to this
probability and therefore we have
established exactly the formula that we
wanted to establish now this derivation
that we carried out here there's nothing
special about the case of three we could
have the union of many more events we
would just have here the product of more
terms and we would need to carry out the
multiplication and we would get cross
terms of all types involving just one of
the indicator variables or products of
two indicator variables or products of
three indicator variables and so on and
after you carry out this exercise and
keep track of the various terms you end
up with this general version of what is
called the inclusion exclusion formula
so the probability of a union is there's
the sum of the probabilities but then
you subtract all possible probabilities
of two-way intersections then we add
probabilities of 3-way intersections
then you subtract probabilities of
four-way intersections and you keep
going this way alternating signs until
you get to the last term which is the
probability of the intersection of all
the events involved and this exponent
here of n minus 1 is the exponent that
you need so that the last term has the
correct sign so for example if n is
equal to 3 the exponent would be 2 so
this could be a plus sign which is
consistent with what we got here so this
is a formula that is quite useful when
you want to calculate probabilities of
unions of events but also this
derivation using
indicator functions is quite beautiful